สวัสดีค่ะครูฟ้าสวัสดีค่ะครูหญิงสวัสดี
ค่ะนักเรียน
สวัสดีค่ะครูฟ้าวันนี้วันอะไรคะวันนี้
วันเสาร์
วันที่เท่าไหร่คะ
วันที่ 19
เดือนอะไรคะ
เดือนสิงหาคม
ปีพ.ศอะไรคะ
ปีพ.ศ
ปีค.ศอะไรคะปีค.ศ
2023 ค่ะเมื่อวานนี้วันอะไรคะ
เมื่อวานนี้วันศุกร์
วันที่เท่าไหร่คะ
วันที่ 18
เดือนอะไรคะ
เดือนสิงหาคม
ปีพ.ศอะไรคะปีพ.ศ
อะไรคะ
ปีค.ศ
2023 ค่ะ
พรุ่งนี้วันอะไรคะ
พรุ่งนี้วันอาทิตย์วันที่เท่าไหร่คะ
วันที่ 14  20 ขอโทษค่ะ
เดือนอะไรคะเดือนสิงหาคม
ปีพ.ศอะไรคะ
ปีพ.ศ
2566 ค่ะปีค.ศอะไรคะ
ปีค.ศ 2023 ค่ะ
ค่ะตอนนี้เวลากี่โมงคะครูฟ้าตอนนี้เวลา
บ่ายโมง
บ่ายโมงกี่นาที
บ่ายโมง 12 นาทีค่ะ
วันนี้เป็นวันเสาร์ใช่ไหมคะวันเสาร์กับ
วันอาทิตย์เนี่ยส่วนใหญ่หลายๆคนเนาะครู
ฟ้าครูหญิงแล้วก็นักเรียนเนี่ยก็ไม่ต้อง
ไปทำงานวันเสาร์วันอาทิตย์นักเรียนก็จะ
อยู่บ้านใช่ไหมอยู่ที่บ้าน
ทำอะไรอยู่ที่บ้าน
ครูฟ้าอยู่บ้านทำอะไรอ่ะคะฟ้าอยู่บ้าน
ใช่ค่ะกินนอนนะ
มันเหม็นก็ต้องซักใช่ไหมแต่ว่า
วันจันทร์
ถึงวันศุกร์ใช่ไหมวันจันทร์ถึงวันศุกร์
เนี่ยครูฟ้าเนี่ยไม่ได้อยู่บ้านครูฟ้า
เนี่ยต้องไปเรียน
นะคะ
เรียนภาษาอังกฤษใช่ไหมคะครูฟ้า
เรียนแล้วก็ทำงาน
แล้วก็ทำงานด้วย
1 วันเนี่ยวันจันทร์ถึงวันศุกร์
[เพลง]
ทำงาน 18 ชั่วโมงไหมหรือมากกว่า
เรียนและทำงานกี่ชั่วโมง
6 ชั่วโมงนอน
6 ชั่วโมงนอนใช่ไหม
6 ชั่วโมงอยู่ที่บ้านนอน 18 ชั่วโมง
เนี่ยไปออฟฟิศแล้วก็ไปเรียนแล้วที่ที่ครู
ฟ้าเนี่ยเรียนภาษาอังกฤษ
มันเป็นตึกไหมคะครูฟ้า
ใช่ค่ะ
เป็นตึก
[เพลง]
เป็นตึกแบบนี้หรอคะครูฟ้า
ใช่ค่ะ
สูงนะคะ
มีกี่ชั้นมาก
[เพลง]
ไม่สูง
อันนี้สูงใช่ไหมตึกสูง
ตึกครูฟ้าเนี่ย
ไม่ได้สูงใช่ไหม
สูงหรือไม่สูงไม่สูงใช่ไหมตึกมี 2 ชั้น
[เพลง]
หรือเปล่าโอเคตึกครูฟ้าเนี่ยนะคะมีแค่นี้
นะคะนักเรียน
มีชั้น 1
แล้วก็ชั้น 2 ไม่สูงไม่สูงเลยค่ะแต่ว่า
ตึกใหญ่ค่ะแต่ไม่สูง
ถ้างั้นเวลาครูฟ้าอยู่ชั้น 1 แล้วครูฟ้า
คิดจะขึ้นชั้น 2 เนี่ยตึกก็น่าจะมีบันได
ใช่ไหม
มีบันได
ใช่แล้ว
มีลิฟต์ไหมคะตึก 2 ชั้นเนี่ยมีบันไดเนี่ย
ชัวร์ 100% แล้วมีลิฟต์
นะคะ
ใช่ไหม
เพราะว่าเวลาที่เราคิดถึงลิฟต์ใช่ไหมคะ
เราจะคิดถึงตึกพระที่ไทยเนาะเอาที่ไทย
แล้วกันนะคะที่ไทยเนี่ยถ้าตึกมีแค่อย่าง
ตึกของครูฟ้าอย่างนี้
มีแค่ 2 ชั้นใช่ไหมชั้น 1 ชั้น 2 ตึกนะคะ
นักเรียนไม่ใช่บ้านมี 2 ชั้นอย่างนี้ตึก
เนี่ยไม่มีลิฟต์
มีแค่บันไดแต่ว่าอันนี้ออสเตรเลียอาจจะมี
ลิฟต์สำหรับคนที่เดินไม่ได้ไง
บางคนเนี่ยนั่งวิวแชร์นั่งรถเข็นถ้าเขา
อยากจะไปชั้น 2 เขาขึ้นขึ้นบันไดไม่ได้
ใช่ไหมเออก็ต้องใส่ลิปมันเข้าใจได้นะคะ
แต่ถ้าที่ไทยใช่ไหมอย่างครูหญิงอยู่
คอนโดมิเนียมคอนโดหญิงเนี่ยก็เป็นตึกแล้ว
ก็สูงเพราะว่ามี
มีตั้งแต่ชั้น 1 ใช่ไหมคะถึงชั้น
29 เนาะมีทั้งหมดเนี่ย 29 ชั้นมีลิฟต์
แน่นอนนะครูหญิงเนี่ยนะคะอยู่ชั้นที่ 18
ถ้าคุณหญิงจะลงไปชั้น 1
Exercise
ครูฟ้าตึกที่โรงเรียนครูฟ้ามี 2 ชั้น
เนี่ยครูฟ้าเรียนชั้น 1 หรือว่าชั้น 2
แวะเรียนชั้น 2 ค่ะ
ครูฟ้าขึ้นบันไดหรือว่าใช้ลิฟต์ขึ้นบันได
ค่ะเพราะว่าดีมาก
มัน 2 ชั้นน่ะ
โอเค
ไม่ต้องใช้ลิปนะคะ
ครูฟ้ากูว่าไม่รู้นะคะแต่ว่าลิฟท์
มัน
มันอยู่ในใช้ได้หรือเปล่าหรอ
ไม่รู้
ใช่ค่ะหรือว่าถ้าบางครั้งลิปอาจจะมีไว้
สำหรับเราเวลาที่เราเนี่ยรีบมากๆไม่มี
เวลาใช่ไหมสมมุติว่า
ครูฟ้าเรียนภาษาอังกฤษก็ต้องมีคุณครูใช่
ไหมคุณครูเนี่ยคุณครูที่สอนภาษาอังกฤษบาง
ที Class อยู่ชั้น 2 ใช่ไหมคะแล้วก็
ครูฟ้าอาจจะเรียน
9 โมง
สมมุตินะสมมุติครูฟ้าเนี่ยเรียน 9 โมงครู
ฟ้าก็มาที่คลาสแล้วแต่บางทีคุณครูรีบหรือ
ว่าครูฟ้าเนี่ยมีคลาส 9 โมงแล้วตอนนี้
เนี่ย
9 โมงแล้วก็ได้
9 โมง 1 นาทีสมัย 9 โมง 1 นาทีแล้วคลาส
เนี่ยเริ่มแล้วครูฟ้ากำลังเดินแล้วก็วิ่ง
กำลังจะไปเรียนอย่างเงี้ยครูฟ้าก็อาจจะ
คิดมีเวลานิดหน่อย
Class เริ่มแล้ว
เอา 9 โมง 5 นาทีดีกว่าครูฟ้าจะได้รีบนัก
เรียนจะได้เข้าใจว่ามันจะได้
ตอนนี้เนี่ย 9:05 นแล้วครูฟ้ายังอยู่ที่
นี่อยู่เลย
ภูฟ้ายังเดินเดินกำลังวิ่งพลัสเนี่ยเริ่ม
แล้วใช่ไหมคะ
เริ่มแล้ว
ครูฟ้าเนี่ยกำลังวิ่งแล้วก็จะขึ้นลิฟท์
มันอาจจะใช้ลิฟท์สมมุติแล้วกันนะ
วันนี้ครูฟ้าแบบรีบมากบันไดไม่โอเคเดี๋ยว
วิ่งไม่ทันกระเป๋ามี
หนังสือมีน้ำแล้วทวีวิงขึ้นบันไดครูฟ้า
เนี่ยก็คิด
9 โมง 5 นาทีแล้วคลาสเริ่มไป 5 นาทีแล้ว
คุณฟ้าจะใช้ดริปนะคะแล้วทีนี้เนี่ย
พอ
แล้วก็เข้าลิฟต์ไม่ทัน
ไม่ทันนะ
ครูฟ้าเนี่ยอย่างแรกเลยนะโดยปกติเนี่ยครู
ฟ้าเนี่ยจะรอรอลิฟต์ตัวต่อไปหรือว่าไม่รอ
คิด
ถ้าตึก 2 ชั้นนะเอาตึก 2 ชั้นก่อนก็ได้
ค่ะถ้ามีคลาสเรียนของครูฝาก
ไม่รอลิฟต์ค่ะเพราะว่าถ้าครูฟ้าเห็นลิฟต์
กำลังจะปิดก็
โอเคบ๊ายบายแล้วก็วิ่งขึ้นบันได
ได้
เพราะว่ามันแค่ 2 ชั้นเองเนาะ
แต่ถ้าไม่ใช่ตึก 2 ชั้น
ไม่ใช่ตึก 2 ชั้นนะคะเป็นตึกที่สูงมากๆ
สมมุติครูฟ้า
เรียนหนังสือตึกที่สูงมากๆอันนี้ชั้น 1
ใช่ไหมคะแต่ครูฟ้าชั้น 2  3
ครูฟ้าเนี่ยเรียนอยู่ชั้นที่ 18 เหมือน
ผู้หญิงเกินไปชั้นที่ 20
Class เนี่ยอาจจะอยู่ชั้นที่ 20 ใช่ไหม
คะแล้วครูฟ้าเนี่ยก็เดินมา
แล้วก็เหมือนเดิมนะคะ Class เนี่ย 9 โมง
ตอนนี้เนี่ย 9 โมง 5 นาทีแล้ว
ครูฟ้าเนี่ยรีบใช่ไหมรีบนะคะจะไปเรียน
แล้วครูฟ้ากำลังวิ่งมาวิ่งมาแล้วก็เจอ
ประตูลิฟท์เนี่ยกำลังจะปิด
ครูฟ้าเรียนอยู่ชั้น 20 เนี่ย
ครูฟ้าจะรอหรือไม่รอลิฟต์ตัวต่อไป
อันนี้บันไดไม่ได้ใช่ไหมชั้น 20 เนี่ย
บันไดน่าจะไม่ไหวนะคะ
คือ
เพราะว่า
ตึกสูงใช่ไหมคะนักเรียน
อาจจะขึ้น
ประมาณ
5-10 นาทีนะ
แต่โดยปกติถ้าตึกสูงอย่างนี้เขาอาจจะมี
ลิฟท์มีลิฟท์นะ
62 ตัวเองหรอโรงเรียนน่าจะมีประมาณ
น่าจะมีลิปประมาณ 2 ตัวเท่านั้นแหละถ้า
เป็นแบบคลาสเป็นโรงเรียนน่ะเนอะ
[เพลง]
จะรอหรือไม่รอ
คือถ้าเป็นครูฟ้านะคะครูฟ้าจะ
รอค่ะ
เพราะว่าลิฟท์ปิดเราทำยังไงล่ะ
รีบปิด
กูก็อาจจะ
ตรงกระเป๋านะคะแล้วก็โยน
นะ
ไม่ช่วยอะไรไหมครูฟ้าเอากระเป๋าโยนเข้าไป
ก็คือกระเป๋าครูฟ้าเนี่ยอยู่ที่นี่อันนี้
กระเป๋าของครูฟ้าแต่ตัวของครูฟ้าเนี่ย
อยู่ที่นี่กระเป๋าเนี่ยอยู่ในลิฟท์ตัว
อยู่ข้างนอกผู้หญิงคิดว่าคนนี้นะคนที่ 1
คนที่อยู่ข้างในเนี่ยคงใจว่าแบบกระเป๋ามี
อะไรโอเคหรือเปล่า
ก็อาจจะโทรนายวันๆนะฮัลโหลตำรวจมีกระเป๋า
อยู่ในลิฟท์ไม่รู้ของใคร
เอ้าเราก็ต้องโยนกระเป๋าให้มันอยู่ตรงนี้
สิผู้หญิง
ให้มันแบบประตูลิฟท์กำลังจะปิดใช่ไหมให้
กระเป๋าเนี่ยมันขวางประตูลิฟท์เพราะว่า
ประตูลิฟต์เนี่ยส่วนใหญ่มันจะเป็น
เซ็นเซอร์ถ้ามันเจออะไรปุ๊บมันจะ
มันจะเปิด
ครูฟ้าถ้าครูฟ้านะไม่เนี่ยแปลว่าครูฟ้า
เป็นคนที่ถ้ามาไม่ทันฤทธิ์กำลังจะปิดครู
ฟ้าเนี่ยรอรอลิฟต์ตัวต่อไปไม่ได้ค่ะถ้า
ครูฟ้าเนี่ยไม่อยากรอลิฟต์ตัวต่อไปโยน
กระเป๋าเนี่ยไม่ได้ถ้าท้องฟ้า
เนี่ยเป็นคนที่จริงๆครูฟ้าเป็นคนตัวสูง
ใช่ไหมใช่ขายาวตัวยาวนะแต่ขาไม่ยาว
ขาเนี่ยยาวยาวเกินแขนเนี่ยก็ยาวถ้าครูฟ้า
เนี่ยรีบวิ่งมาแล้วประตูลิฟท์เนี่ยกำลัง
จะปิดครูฟ้าไม่ต้องโยนกระเป๋าค่ะครูฟ้ามี
กระเป๋าใช่ไหมแล้วก็เอากระเป๋าเนี่ย
เอากระเป๋าไปขวางปุ๊บมันจะเปิดเองเลยไม่
ต้องอยู่แล้ว
ว่า
ครูฟ้าเนี่ยถ้าครูฟ้าวิ่งยังไงก็ไม่ทัน
ลิฟท์เนี่ยติดอยู่ดีเมื่อวานก็ต้องคิดว่า
ระหว่างครูฟ้ากับลิฟต์เนี่ยมันห่างกัน
เนี่ยกี่เมตร
ใช่ไหมห่างกี่เมตร
ครูฟ้าก็ต้องรอตัวต่อไปแต่ถ้ามันใกล้แล้ว
อ่ะอีกนิดเดียวครูฟ้าเนี่ยเดินอีก 1  2  2
9 เนี่ยก็ถึงลิฟท์แล้วครูฟ้าก็ค่อยเอา
กระเป๋าเนี่ย
อยู่ตรงกลางระหว่างตรงนี้ใช่ไหมระหว่าง
ประตูลิฟต์ที่มันกำลังจะปิดมา
เนี่ยประตูลิฟต์ที่มันกำลังจะปิดมาอย่าง
เงี้ยเออมันจะโดนเซ็นเซอร์แล้วมันจะเปิด
เพราะว่าหลายๆคนเนี่ยนะคะถ้าเขารีบแล้ว
ไม่อยากรอลิฟต์ตัวต่อไปเพราะว่ามันเหมือน
ที่ครูฟ้าบอกไงมันอาจจะใช้เวลาแบบ 5 ถึง
10 นาที
โดยเฉพาะตึกสูงๆแล้วก็มีลิฟต์อยู่แค่ 2
ตัวอย่างเงี้ยค่ะถ้าเรารีบใช่ไหมเราใช้
กระเป๋าใช้มือของตัวเองออกไปขวางประตูใช้
เท้า
หายหลายคนใช่เพราะว่ามือเนี่ยบางทีแบบมัน
กระแทกมือมันเจ็บไง
ขาวเท้าก็เจ็บนะคะหรือว่าขา
ใช่ไหมขาเนี่ยมันก็แบบโอ้ย
เจ็บ
แต่ว่าบางทีลิปอ่ะลิปดีๆอ่ะนะมันจะไม่
กระแทกเราใช่ไหมมันจะเป็นเซ็นเซอร์แล้วก็
เปิดแต่ถ้าครูฟ้าเนี่ยอยู่ไกล
ไม่ใช่แบบ
ไม่ใช่อยู่ใกล้ๆแบบเอ่อ
1 เมตร 1 เมตรมันใกล้ไหม
1 เมตรก็ใกล้อยู่นะ 500 เมตร
ถ้าครูฟ้าอยู่ซัก 500 เมตรที่มันไกลอ่ะนะ
มันไกลหน่อยเนาะ
ครูฟ้าคิดโอ้มันไกลมากๆครูฟ้าจะทำยังไง
ครูฟ้าไม่อยากรอลิฟท์ตัวต่อไป
โยนกระเป๋าอันนี้น่ากลัวใช่ไหมแต่มือหรือ
ว่าแขนแขนของเรามันก็ไม่ได้ยาวพอขาหรือ
ตัวใช่มั้ยเรารู้สึกสามารถเอาตัวเขาไป
อย่างเงี้ยก็ไม่ได้ครูฟ้าก็ไม่ต้องโยน
กระเป๋าก็ได้ค่ะเอ้าถ้าครูฟาร์มไม่โยน
กระเป๋าทำยังไงเนี่ยแล้วก็ครูฟ้ามีปากใช่
ไหม
พูดได้ไหม
รอด้วย
เฮ้ยค่ะแต่ว่าไม่ใช่แบบภูฟ้าอยู่ 500
เมตรใช่ไหมไกลจากลิฟต์ไม่ได้แบบเดินแค่
สองก้าวอ่ะอุ้ย
ลบไม่ได้นะคะครูฟ้าอาจจะต้องวิ่งแล้วก็
ลิฟต์แล้วครูฟ้าต้องตะโกน
ตะโกนบอกเลย
รอด้วยค่ะ
ใช่ค่ะ
แล้วแบบคนในลิฟต์เนี่ยเวลาอยู่ข้างในตรง
นี้ใช่ไหมคะมันก็จะมีปุ่มเนาะ
ที่เป็นชั้นน่ะเนาะ
แต่มันเป็นวงกลมๆไว้ให้เรากดเนี่ยนะคะนัก
เรียนมันจะเป็นแบบที่เวลาเราเป็นเด็กเรา
ชอบเล่นน่ะนะคะ
ชั้น 1 ชั้น 2 ชั้น 3 ตรงนี้เนี่ยมันจะมี
ปุ่มเปิดใช่ไหม
ผู้หญิงก็วาดไม่ค่อยเป็นนะคะนักเรียนมัน
จะมีปุ่มเนี่ยให้เรากดกดเอาไว้แล้วก็
ประตูลิฟท์เนี่ยเปิดพอครูฟ้าเนี่ยตะโกน
ตะโกนบอกว่าให้คนในลิฟต์เนี่ยรอด้วยค่ะ
สมมุติผู้หญิงคนนี้ใช่ไหมเขาอยู่ในลิฟต์
เขาได้ยินที่ครูฟ้าพูดเขาก็จะกดปุ่มนี้
ค้างเอาไว้ลิปมันก็จะเปิดแล้วก็ครูฟ้าก็
วิ่งมาแล้วก็เข้าไปได้ไม่ต้องเขวี้ยง
กระเป๋านะคะหรือว่าต้องโยนกระเป๋า
อันนี้คิดว่าเป็น
คนส่วนใหญ่ทำนะแต่ผู้หญิงคิดว่ามากๆเลยก็
คือทุกคนจะตะโกนบอกว่ารอด้วยค่ะ
ใช่ออสเตรเลีย
เขาไม่เข้าใจนี่ไงอันนี้คือครูฟ้าเลยนะ
ครูฟ้าอยู่ที่นี่
แล้วก็ที่เหลือเนี่ยเป็นฝรั่งฝรั่งฝรั่ง
ฝรั่งครูฟ้าพูดรอด้วยค่ะ
ครูฟ้าก็จำคำภาษาอังกฤษว่าภาษาอังกฤษคำ
ว่ารอพูดอะไรก็พูด
แล้วก็ต้องมีคำว่า Please นะภาษาอังกฤษ
ยาวนะคะ can  you
please กว่าจะพูดเสร็จนี้ปิดแล้ว
ถ้าเรารีบใช่ไหมเราไม่อยากรอเราก็ต้องทำ
ยังไงก็ได้ให้คนในลิฟต์เนี่ยรู้ว่าเรา
เนี่ยจะไปด้วยใช่ไหมคะก็อะไรคะครูฟ้าแล้ว
ทำอย่างอื่นได้อีกไหม
ได้สิมีอะไรอีก
ไม่ค่อยมีเราไหมส่วนใหญ่ก็จะตะโกนใช้ตัว
เองในการรอใช้ตัวเองก็คือเอามือเอาแขน
เข้าไปขวางเอาตัวเข้าไปเอากระเป๋า
โยน
ไม่อยู่
เอากระเป๋าเนี่ยเอาไปขวางประตูเอาไว้ไงทำ
ยังไงก็ได้ที่เราจะยืนที่มันจะอยู่ตรงนี้
อันนี้เป็นประตูใช่ไหมให้มันขวางประตูเอา
ไว้ให้ประตูเนี่ยมันไม่ปิดนะคะแต่ก็ไม่
รู้เหมือนกันว่านักเรียนเนี่ยทำยังไงฆ่า
นักเรียนเนี่ยไม่อยากรอลิฟต์ตัวต่อไปจะ
เข้าตัวนี้แล้วนักเรียนรีบนะนักเรียนจะทำ
ยังไงก็คอมเม้นคุยกับเราได้นะคะส่วน
วีดีโอนี้เนี่ยผู้หญิงกับครูฟ้าไปก่อนให้
ครูฟ้าเขาไปฝึกโยนกระเป๋าก่อนนะคะ
เดี๋ยวเรามาเจอกันใหม่วีดีโอหน้าสวัสดี
ค่ะสวัสดีค่ะ